RACHEL TSAO: Hello, and welcome
to Top Use Cases to Start Your
Serverless Journey.
My name is Rachel
Tsao, Product Manager
for Serverless at Google Cloud.
Today, I'm joined by my
colleague Preston Holmes.
We'll cover the
benefits and use cases
of using Google Cloud
serverless compute.
We'll start with why modernizing
is beneficial for everyone,
whether you're an
established enterprise
or a fast-growing
digital native.
We'll cover why Google
Cloud serverless.
We'll dive into why
serverless is a good fit
for pragmatic enterprises.
And then I will hand
it over to Preston
to talk about great workloads
for your serverless journey.
Let's start with why modernize.
As we look towards
the future, there
is a growing need for
companies to create value
through application design.
Companies are looking to delight
customers with responsiveness,
derive value from data,
and be insights driven,
respond faster to
change quickly,
and be secure and available
in regions globally.
They also want to be well-run
with effective cost management
while being able
to scale quickly
to potentially
millions of users.
These characteristics
are no longer
just a choice, but an
expectation from customers.
But companies face
barriers internally.
These include people and
organizational barriers,
like a lack of confidence in new
technology, a need for control,
a lack of cloud-native
skills, a lack of automation.
It can also be resistance
to change, [INAUDIBLE],, lack
of innovation, lack
of cost optimization,
and the need to comply
with security policies.
Overcoming these barriers
with a cloud-native strategy
is important as
modern applications
are able to achieve
outstanding outcomes, including
being dynamic, scalable,
and intelligent.
These characteristics
are increasingly
important for them to meet
fast-changing user needs.
A cloud-native
strategy is possible,
whether your company is
migrating from virtual machines
or building new
applications cloud native.
When a company is
migrating from VMs,
they often face tight budgets,
security concerns, the need
to maintain legacy
infrastructure,
and the need to migrate
and modernize their APIs.
Modernizing to serverless can
help meet many of these demands
in a way that is developer
friendly while considering
costs and time to market.
Similarly, building
new applications
requires services to be
built in a way that reacts
to market and customer demands.
For these new
applications, we developers
want to use the
latest technology.
We don't want to
think about upgrades.
We want to take advantage of
the new economics provided
by the cloud, and we want
architectural portability
so we are not locked in.
No matter where
you are starting,
serverless is a great
choice and meets
demand of modern applications.
Now, let's explore why
Google Cloud serverless.
Serverless is a set
of characteristics.
It simplifies the
developer experience
by eliminating the need
to manage infrastructure.
It is scalable out of
the box, whether you
want to scale down
to 0 with no traffic,
or up to millions of users.
It has a pay-as-you-use model,
where you pay for exactly what
you use instead of guessing
the capacity upfront.
If you don't have any traffic,
you don't pay for anything.
Serverless technology enables
companies to quickly build,
develop, and deploy any
application in a fully
automated environment.
It removes the
operational burden
of infrastructure management
with built-in security,
operations, and
DevOps best practices.
As our customer
needs have evolved,
we've built our serverless
compute portfolio
to enable them in
their journeys.
As many of you know, App Engine
was one of the first serverless
solutions to market in
2008, and early customers
took advantage of
serverless and App Engine
as they scaled their
web applications
across millions of users
on Google's infrastructure.
We then added the ability to
run functions in the service
to our serverless
portfolio in 2017.
With Cloud Functions, we give
customers a simple developer
experience with the ability
to rapidly write and run
tiny snippets of code.
In parallel, Google also
introduced innovations
to the container
market with Kubernetes,
and we started to
hear from customers
who wanted to know if
we could combine the two
awesome serverless attributes
of autoscaling and developer
experience with the
flexibility of containers.
In response, we introduced
Cloud Run, the next generation
of serverless.
Serverless is no longer about
event-driven programming
or microservices.
It's also about running
complex workloads at scale
while preserving a delightful
developer experience.
In fact, serverless
with Cloud Run
is about having a true developer
platform with the flexibility
to run any language,
any library, any binary.
Serverless offers the
following benefits.
The infrastructure
is managed by Google,
meaning that you
benefit from deploying
on the same infrastructure
as Google engineers.
Your engineers do not need
to think or spend time
worrying about scale.
Because you only pay for
when there is traffic,
it often enables
great cost savings.
And finally,
serverless is secure.
Google manages
infrastructure-level security
for you, ensuring that you
have the latest patches.
You can choose from a suite of
Google Cloud security features
to meet your business needs.
Google Cloud serverless
is the pragmatic choice
for enterprises,
and it's not just
for lightweight applications,
like this zippy golf cart
you might imagine here.
We're actually enabling all
kinds of heavy duty workloads,
like this tractor.
In fact, this year, we unlocked
several security features
on Cloud Run, making it even
more secure for enterprises.
With Binary Authorization
and Manage Secrets,
you can ensure your
application is safe to run.
With Cloud Armor support,
identity-aware proxy,
ingress settings,
and IAM ingress,
you can ensure the
right folks have access.
And finally, you can understand
what your application can
access with restriction
egress out of VPC,
intelligent security
recommendations,
and VPC-SC network
egress settings.
We've also unlocked new
pricing options on Cloud Run.
Out of the box, you
only pay for what you
use for under 200 milliseconds.
And this year, we introduced
committed use discounts,
meaning that if you commit
to one or three years,
you can save up to 17%.
And finally, we also introduced
CPU allocation controls,
meaning that if you
have a workload that
needs to run continuously, we
do not charge for service fees
to start Cloud Run back
up every single time.
In addition, all our
serverless products
offer built-in observability
and monitoring without setup.
For example, requests
and container logs
are automatically sent to
Cloud Logging from Cloud Run.
And error reporting
is automatically
enabled for Cloud Run.
No additional setup or
configuration is required.
You can simply view logs
on the Cloud Run page,
and also in the Cloud
Logging console.
Choosing Google
Cloud serverless can
help eliminate
operational overhead,
manage costs, all in
an innovative building
model with easier scalability.
Now I'll hand it over
to Preston to see
what workloads are a great fit.
PRESTON HOLMES: Thanks, Rachel.
So let's talk about
some of these workloads.
You'll note that in
Google Cloud platform,
we have a range of options
to run the compute portion
of your application code.
And these can be
broadly laid out
on a spectrum between
convenience and control.
So we've got Cloud Functions
for very small, lightweight
snippets of code.
We've got serverless
containers with Cloud Run.
We've got cluster-based
infrastructure
in Kubernetes and GKE.
And then, for VMs, we've
got Google Compute Engine.
So, many of these workloads
are potentially a better fit
for one of these than another.
But rather than create
a large decision tree,
we've decided to pick out
three workloads that we think
are a particularly good fit
for serverless and Cloud Run,
and those are web applications,
data processing, and APIs.
Now, I'll actually
speak to a little bit
of a sub flavor of each of these
to give it a bit more context
of where you can get started.
And so, for web
applications, I'm
going to talk about
intranet web applications.
So these are applications
designed to be accessed only
by company employees.
And what we want
to do is we want
to bring you a bit of
how we get to interact
with our internal applications
at Google, which Google
has published some research
about we call BeyondCorp.
And that is, at
Google, we no longer
use VPNs to access
internal applications.
Instead, we use very secure
Identity Aware proxies
that can use context
about an employee
to make sure they
have access only
to the right internal
applications.
Now, we have externalized
this in Cloud platform
as the Identity
Aware proxy, and we
can put that in front of
our serverless Cloud Run
applications.
The idea of IAP is
that we only want
authorized and corporate
employees to be able to access
those internal applications.
And they should not be
accessible by the public.
But at the same
time, we don't want
to burden our
internal developers
with having to
recreate and reproduce
a secure posture for each
new intranet application.
Instead, that should
be globally handled
by a frontend system
that will make sure
only our employees are
accessing these applications.
Now, this is
specifically delivered
through a composition and
integration of Google Cloud
platform products.
It starts with Cloud Identity,
which provides an identity
service so that we know who it
is that's logging into our web
applications.
It can then be guarded with
Cloud Armor, a web application
firewall that does things
like rate limiting, protection
of our applications, or can
whitelist certain IP ranges.
We then hit the
Identity Aware proxy.
This gives our users
that user login flow.
So it makes sure
that every access
to the actual application
has been authorized
and only identified
users are logging in.
And then, finally,
the load balancer
distributes these requests to
multiple different intranet
apps.
So let's take a look at a
demo of this in practice
and see what it can look
like at your company.
So here you can see
the intranet project
I have set up with several
example applications already
deployed.
I have an Intranet Home app.
This acts as the
home page for listing
all of my other applications.
And then a Birthdays application
and a Vacations application.
You'll note that the ingress
setting for all of these
is set to internal
and load balancing.
What that means is that these
are not reachable directly
from the internet.
You can see, while this URL
is here, it's grayed out
and is not directly accessible.
This is actually enforced
for any new Cloud Run
application deployed
through organization policy.
So for the entire project or
maybe a folder of projects,
I can set that the only allowed
values for this ingress setting
is internal traffic only, or
internal plus load balancing.
So we are running
these applications
behind a load
balancer, and we have
two backend services set up.
The first is really just
used as our catchall to route
to that intranet home page.
The other is using a wild
card pattern in the host rule.
And what that wild
card pattern does
is allow us to use a
single mask applications
network endpoint group.
This network
endpoint group takes
advantage of a feature with
its own URL mask there.
And this service
placeholder in the URL mask
means that for every new
intranet application I
deploy that has a service
name, I automatically
have the route set up to reach
that particular Cloud Run
service in the
single load balancer
without needing
to manually create
each additional backend for
each new intranet application.
Now, the BeyondCorp
part of this is
that I run these behind
the Identity Aware proxy.
This will force the login flow
to reach these applications.
I actually have this set
up to use our organization
only as a source of identity.
So this is limited just
to our organization.
The last thing we'll do here is
just check on public DNS Google
to see that the domain name
I have set up with my load
balancer is resolving.
And it does.
It resolves to this
IP address, which
is the same as that set up
in the load balancer here.
So with that, let's
take a look at what
the login flow looks like.
Again, this will be the
first-time login for a user.
And if I do that, I'm given
a standard login dialog here.
This is using, in this
case, my Google account.
But we could also use a
corporate SSO flow for IAP.
And now I'm on the
intranet home page.
Now, I'm seeing a couple
other of the applications
I can get to.
So for example, I can
schedule some time off.
This will route me to
the Vacations service
that has got its own hostname
path behind this load balancer.
I could also go to
the Birthday service.
And again, this will route
to that individual Cloud Run
service.
Each of these can be
independently managed
and deployed by different
groups, or teams, or authors.
And in fact, you see that IAP
will pass through information
about the logged in user.
So applications can make use of
a already authenticated value
for the current
user to do things
like user-specific
profiles or updates,
or further rule-based
authorization.
Now, subsequent logins
to this will not
require any particular
auth flow, except subject
to sort of any timeouts policy
my org has set up because this
is using cookies to
remember this login
for some period of time.
If I try to log in as a user
from some non-organization user
account, you'll see
that I don't even
have the option of logging
in because the entire auth
application is limited to
only organization users.
So this will be another
layer of defense
that prevents anyone from
accidentally enabling
specific permission to a user.
That's an option on IAP that
you can set up and either allow
that or not allow that.
So you're not forced to do that.
But if you do want to keep
this as an organization-only
intranet setup, you can do that.
And so deploying
a new intranet app
is pretty much
just as easy as now
deploying another
container-based Cloud Run
service.
Each of these scales down
to 0 and makes it very easy.
Great, now that we've taken
a look at internet web
applications, let's take
a look at data processing.
Now, data processing is really
a catchall or umbrella term
that might cover any number of
types of changes or mutations
you're going to make
to the data you have,
which include converting
data, packaging data,
validating data.
So it really covers a
wide range of use cases.
So let's take a
look at something
that's a bit more
specific, which
is performing some
lightweight data processing
at the time of ingest.
Now, on Cloud Platform,
we have a product
called Cloud Pub/Sub,
which is really
great at delivering messages
to many of our backend data
processing systems.
And as an architectural
component,
it's often very useful to
decouple the producers of data
from those systems
which will consume it.
But there are times that
you need to bring data
into your platform.
This might be video
game telemetry.
Might be device data.
It might be some sort
of external log ingest
where what you want to do is
not completely decouple this
at the point of ingest.
So you might want to provide
custom authentication
at the point of ingest.
Or you might want to validate
the contents of each message
and make sure that only good
and verified data is making it
onto the Pub/Sub topic.
And so Cloud Run acts as a very
nice, scalable point of ingest
where you can both
receive the data into GCP,
as well as perform some
lightweight data processing
at that point of ingest.
Another one of the use
cases we want to talk today
is about REST APIs.
Now, REST APIs are not
a brand new use case.
In fact, they've
been around a while.
But they still remain
a real bread and butter
of many enterprise IT projects.
This is often where you
have multiple surfaces
in the backend composed into
a single API service, where
each backend microservice
might be only contributing
one element of an
overall API experience.
So in this case, we have a
hypothetical weather service
where you might have
alerts, forecast, locations,
each being fulfilled
by a separate backend
and independently
deployed microservice.
Now, these are all
routed through some sort
of API management
system, often serving
the need of authentication,
or rate limiting,
or quota management.
And then these reach the end
user application and either
a client or a mobile
web application.
One of the customers using Cloud
Run in this case is ecobee.
ecobee uses Cloud Run for API
services, driving experience,
and functionality in
their customer-facing web
and mobile applications.
This has allowed
engineering teams
to ship new features
to their customers
faster, as new services
can be turned up in days,
and iteration is made faster
by using the same serverless
technologies to simplify QA
environments, streamlining
the path from code
to production.
By using fully managed
databases together
with serverless
compute, services
scale smoothly and
reliably as a whole.
These technologies have led to
greater operational efficiency,
removing many of
the incident pages
which were due purely to
infrastructure issues instead
of the applications themselves.
And with that, I
want to thank you
on behalf of Rachel and
myself for joining us today.